after days of uncertainty an unrest
across Nigeria this is the man who is
named himself leader of the new
transitional government
our action is motivated by the soul
desire to preserve our beloved Homeland
on the one hand in the face of our
deterioration of the security situation
of our country the president caused this
crisis with poor economic and social
governance
had been the head of the presidential
guard since 2015. a military Brigade
charged with protecting the
democratically elected president toppled
him on Wednesday and detained him
Jenny's appointment followed two days of
chaos and demonstrations in the capital
Miami where crowds set fire to cars and
buildings near the headquarters of the
governing party
[Applause]
supporters of the coup celebrate outside
the National Assembly and upload the
Army's decision to support the coup
we've always believed in the Army
despite conditions that have tried to
destabilize it we believe that the Army
by taking power will create the
conditions for the Army to regain its
values
this is a fifth call in Nigeria in three
years and it's not alone in the region
Mali and Burkina Faso have had two
military coups each in that time
the above five or six countries all
seeking to improve the Jazz capacity to
fight the jihadists they've made big
promises okay so what kind of assistance
is it that is Maori field Burkina Faso
failed it has failed in Niger we need to
ask the hard questions when our partners
come bearing gifts
what types of gifts are they
sweets a group of soldiers appeared on
television on Wednesday blaming the
president for a worsening security and
economic mismanagement
an unstable ninja however could further
destabilize the Sahar region and the
fight against armed groups linked to
ayok Aida and isil
the African Union the United States
Germany Russia the United Nations and
France have all called for the immediate
release of President Muhammad bazoom
is totally illegitimate and deeply
dangerous for the people of Niger for
Niger itself and for the whole region
the deposed president is still held by
the military
I don't know exactly where he is but he
was detained
he told me he was well
but he told me that the situation was
very serious
International pressure is on to return
Ninja's elected president to power but
the latest announcement of a new leader
could mean a long difficult negotiation
process to restore democracy in a
country once seen as an island of
stability in West Africa Ahmed Idris Al
Jazeera